hi this is presh talwalkar and today
we're going to present the four nights
puzzle
the setup is a three by three grid
and
knights are placed on the four corners
they move according to the normal chess
rules which is you can move two spots
over and one up
or
two spots up and one over
the goal in this puzzle is only by using
legal chess moves can you get the
question is can you get the knights in
the opposite corners to swap positions
so the thing you should give this a try
it will be very could be frustrating at
first because
as you move the knight you're going to
realize
it it's going to occupy a square that
you want to move the other knight into
so you're constantly going to have to
keep going back and forth
and the question is can you get the
knights to swap positions
and if so what is the minimum number of
moves
you should definitely give this a try
once you're ready you can continue
watching the video and listen to the
solution
so the reason this puzzle is interesting
is you can get a very
interesting solution using graph theory
and we're going to start off with a very
simple technique what we're going to do
is we're going to draw a line between
two squares
if a knight can move from once
between those two squares
so the knight on a1 can definitely move
to c2
but it could also move to b3
and from those positions it can move to
different squares
and we're just going to draw lines that
connect them
uh once we get to this final move right
here we've actually completed a circuit
and we can't create any more unique
arrows everything is already been done
before
and this is going to help us solve the
puzzle so what we do is we're going to
abstract once more and make the board
disappear
and we will label
the endpoints
of the graph with the corresponding
scores that they uh
they represent
and we'll also just move the knights
over to the spots
so how is this going this graph going to
get us to the solution
well it looks like a complicated graph
with a lot of lines
uh overlapping intersecting
so we're just going to
rearrange this graph and unfold it just
think about it like game of cat's cradle
so we start out with this point c2 over
here we're just gonna move it over
and keep keeping the same links
connected
so all we've done is we've sort of
pulled out the c2
and we're going to keep doing this now
we're going to take
this a3 over here and we're going to
pull it out
and we keep doing this we'll we'll pull
out b1
we'll move over uh a2
and then
b3
and c1
so this is exactly the same graph that
we had before that star-shaped graph is
just we've rearranged it to make a
circuit
and finally what we can do
is
all the
links between the different squares are
the same so we'll just renormalize this
and draw it to an octagon
so now this is exactly the same
graph we've
but it's a much simpler representation
we have the four knights we have the
spots that they can move to
and this will get us to solve the puzzle
the only way that we can get the knight
on a1 and c3 to swap positions
and c1 and a3 to swap positions is we're
going to have to rotate this graph
either clockwise or counterclockwise
four spaces
this means
that each knight is going to have to
move over four spaces
and this puzzle can be solved and it can
be solved in a minimum of 16 moves
so that's the elegant answer
i hope you enjoyed this puzzle
and you
uh
subscribe to me so because i do math and
game theory
videos you can also
read more about my stuff on my blog
mindyourdecisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker and get my ebooks at
amazon